- Hi, what a do.
Welcome to another episode of Real Mature.
It's a show we make about
things you do when you grow up.
And one of the things you
do when you grow up is
you get to know your
family in a different way.
So we have three different videos we made
about people getting
to know their families.
And the first one kinda starts with me,
so that's why there's
like no one else here.
But usually there's another person.
So we're just gonna get into it.
You guys ready?
You ready Jenny?
You ready?
Boom, let's do it.
(funky jazz music)
- So the first video we
want to show you actually
started with another, much worse,
idea for a video that our team had.
Basically, my parents are
coming into the office.
I manage this team, and everyone was like,
"Wouldn't it be funny if we make a video
"where we get to ask Henry's
parents questions about Henry?"
- I'd love to see your impressions of him.
"Hey, I'm Henry!"
- Oh, no no, my impression of Henry,
I don't have my phone, is texting.
- On a scale of one to ten,
how much do you want Henry to get married?
- Retell.
- Really?
- So one interesting thing happened,
which is our friend Mark
didn't really understand
the idea of the thing.
He didn't ask my parents
an embarrassing question,
he just asked a question he
wanted to know about life.
And my parents kinda had like
a really interesting answer.
- Is it worth having kids?
- Of course it is.
There's nothing in the world like it.
- Every parent, I hear
every parent say that
about having kids.
Like, the tough parts.
- A downside is every parent
worries some about their kids.
You know, wants them to have a good life.
Wants them to be happy.
When things don't go well for them,
they don't go well for parents.
That's a reflection of love,
but it's also sometimes tough.
- We thought it'd be interesting
if we just got people
to call their parents
and ask them a question
they never thought to ask
and see if we could all
learn something about life.
Hanging out, get to know our
parents a little bit better.
And first, we have a
video that Colin made.
Colin, tell us about our video.
- We got contacted by a
woman who got thrown into
a pretty interesting living dynamic
where she got to know
her siblings pretty well.
- You wanna give us more?
That's kinda vague.
- That was pretty vague.
- I liked it, I thought it was good.
- Okay, well then, just
cut to the video then.
(laughs)
- Fine.
- [Isabel] So this time last year,
I was working full time.
I was living in my own apartment
with my two best friends,
and just kinda had a normal life.
Priority was all just kind of about work
and doing that early 20
thing of trying to move up.
I was doing that.
I got a call from a friend who
was over at my dad's house.
He's been sick since
I was seven years old.
It kept going up and down,
he had prostate cancer.
So I didn't necessarily
think it was a big deal,
I thought she was just getting nervous
about the way he always was.
But everything changed.
I left my job, my mother just
wasn't capable of parenting.
Before he went into the hospital,
my dad had asked me to
take care of the twins
if he passed away.
(light piano music)
- Nobody that I know is being raised
by their sisters.
Which I guess is pretty cool.
- I was definitely, for
lack of better terms,
probably a little bit
more on the selfish side.
- Charlotte had actually
moved home to save up money
to travel around the world.
- And so now I'm sharing a
room with a 15-year-old girl.
And it's different.
- So obviously in this day and age,
if you're faced with a problem,
the first thing you do is Google.
And there was nothing there.
- I think that's actually why Izzie
started doing the blog.
Also because she couldn't
find anything online.
- Just talk about what we're doing,
so next time someone
else goes through this,
there's something to reach out to
and something to read about,
at least the daily experience of it all.
It's cool, it's cool
that it's actually within
a matter of months, it's helping people.
Normally we're on the same
page about everything.
And we're really good
at when the twins ask
for something big that we
know they're gonna hold us to,
we'll say, "Oh, I have to
talk to Charlotte first."
Or she'll say, "Oh, I have
to talk to Isabel first."
As long as we do that, we're fine.
(laughs)
- [Charlotte] I couldn't
imagine just not being
part of this, to be honest.
Me and Isabel definitely
had like our moments
where we were like debating not living
together in this situation.
The question was never,
"Am I gonna leave the
raising the kids?" part,
it's just, "How do we make it work?"
where me and Isabel are in a situation
where we're getting along.
- Charlotte and I have had our
ups and downs through this,
but I don't know what I'd do without her.
Like, we co-parent.
I legally have guardianship,
but it's a lot of work for one person.
- I'm older by three minutes.
He always says it's two,
but I'm, it's three.
- It's probably three.
- It's three.
- I think that at the beginning,
it was really, you know,
learning how to make sure
that all the bills were paid on time.
And like, actually being head of household
rather than just a 23-year-old
girl with an apartment
that I pay like rent,
electricity, and gas.
You know, it's like now
there's budgeting for food,
and budgeting for making sure
that they have clothes on their backs,
and random school projects that come up.
Just making sure that all
of your ducks are in a row
before you need them to be in a row,
which is, it's daunting.
- [Jasper] What about this one, Charlotte?
- [Charlotte] That's
the one where Isabel's
upset that I was being born.
(all laugh)
- [Isabel] I'm like, "Do
we have to keep her?"
- My dad was the best dad.
He didn't love anyone in the world
more than he loved us.
No matter where he was,
he was telling people
about his kids and what they were up to,
even when they didn't wanna listen.
- At his funeral,
everyone's telling stories.
And one person was like, "I
just remember this one time
"that we had a party bus,
"and Harvey was like passing wine
"out to the people on the street."
He knew how to walk into
the room and own it,
and how to talk to everybody,
and how to make everyone
feel better about themselves.
It was just, he was a cool dude.
He was really fun, I miss him.
- There's the thought
of what life should be
versus what life is.
But that's not a way to live a life.
I just try to do as good
a job as he did for us
with the twins, which is pretty high bar.
- That was a cool video.
Colin's been working on
that for a long time.
So next, I'm gonna go see
if Hillary wants to call
her parents and ask them
another question about life.
Hey guys.
- Hi.
- Hey.
(funky jazz music)
- Calling Hillary's mom, you guys.
- Very anti being in videos.
- What up?
- [Hillary] This is Henry.
- [Henry] Hi, nice to meet you, Mrs. Rudy.
- Hi, Henry.
- Do you want to switch the--
we flip the phone so it's sideways.
Yeah, perfect.
So we're doing this
thing where we're having
people just call their
parents and ask them questions
that they normally wouldn't ask.
And Hillary has a question
which we picked out for her,
which she's gonna ask you.
And then we'd just love
to hear your answer.
- Okay.
- Okay, how do you think you are different
from me when you were my age?
- Well, I was much more conservative.
Much more concerned about
pleasing other people than myself,
doing the right thing.
And I was a lot straighter then.
And, that's it.
- Do you wish you had been
more like Hillary is now
when you were her age?
- I would love to be like Hillary.
Every possible way.
She's my idol, and I'm very,
very proud to be her mother.
- Awwww.
- Thanks, mom.
- Cool, that's it, that's all we got.
- I guess you've heard enough from me.
- (both laugh) That was wonderful,
thank you so much for doing this.
- Good, well maybe you
won't call me for any more
of these videos in that case.
(laughs)
- Love you!
- Ciao bella!
- So, the next video is
a video that Jenny made
about getting to know her family.
Jenny, what was your video about?
- Well, I'm Cuban, my
whole family's Cuban.
And my grandfather, along with my family,
came to the states about 60 years ago,
and this is about finding
something that was once lost.
(upbeat salsa music)
- [Male Voice] Cuba, cuba.
(laughter)
- Ahhh.
We have two ladies from Miami here
to tell us a little bit about Cuban food.
Dmitri and I--
- I'm just an idiot,
I don't know anything.
- I'm an idiot, Dmitri's an idiot.
We have never really
experienced Cuban food.
We don't know what the
hell's going on here.
I'm gonna eat off of all of
your plates, if that's alright.
- Yeah, of course.
- Allie, have you ever been to Cuba?
- I have not.
- And you have also not been to Cuba?
- Some of my family
members are planning a trip
in the not-too-distant future.
So it's possible.
- Things are changing.
- It's definitely something
I've wanted to do all my life.
(upbeat salsa music)
- So that sorta brings
us to why we're here.
A couple of weeks ago,
Jenny and I were on a shoot together
for a video I was making
about meeting my neighbors.
And, while we were stuck in
traffic and just chatting,
Jenny mentioned to me that her grandfather
used to be a painter,
and that all of his paintings
were somewhere in Cuba,
and they had no idea where.
- The local movie theaters
would hire him to draw like
Clark Gable, and John Wayne,
and all these famous American stars.
They had to leave every single one
with different neighbors
and family members
scattered about Cuba.
- And he's been gone since 1959, '58.
- Yeah, since he took
that Peter Pan flight.
- And now he's 93?
- About to be 93 in August, yes.
- So when he got to
America, what happened then?
- He gave up painting.
They weren't in a good position in Cuba,
so it was a much worse situation in Miami.
One of my cousins from Cuba,
she got a Facebook account,
and we just started talking.
Found out that one of our neighbors kept
probably the painting that meant
the most to my grandfather.
(female voice speaking Spanish)
(speaking Spanish)
- [Jenny] Imagine, they
haven't talked to him in years.
Like, the last time they saw him,
he was like 26, like our age, you know.
- Do you guys have any
questions at this point?
- No, I mean, this is incredible.
I'm just sorta like in awe right now.
- Yeah, I'm riveted.
- It turns out that he
drew this apparently
when he was 17 years old.
It was one of his first paintings.
- He's 93 now, so that's like late '30s.
- We have cousins that
moved to Miami from Cuba
about five years ago,
but they still travel frequently to Cuba.
When we found out that the
painting was still in existence,
we talked to him, and he's like,
"Well, I'm going to a wedding."
He was very nervous about still trying
to take that through the
airport with the frame.
- 'Cause it's still like smuggling now.
- When he rolled it up and
put it into a duffel bag,
but then some funny things happened.
- [Dmitri] There's more?
- Yeah, this is when it gets weird.
(Jenny laughs)
- Just that short trip from Cuba to Miami,
it broke into pieces.
- Oh my god.
- It was a jigsaw puzzle.
My closest, closest, my bestest friend,
was like, "Can you put this together?"
Like, he did it in about three days,
and there's that painting,
like on the table.
And there was still pieces missing,
like little scraps, we're like,
"Oh, that's the end of the tail," or
"That's the corner of this."
(speaking Spanish)
(upbeat salsa music)
- [Jenny] My grandfather is a very,
like he keeps his emotions to himself.
And he was more quiet.
But you could just read it off of him.
- [Female Voice] Two, three, smile for me.
(camera clicks) I love it.
- [Jenny] He was just more
floored than anything.
- My heart is pounding.
Is it okay right now?
Where is the painting right now?
- It's hanging in my grandparent's house.
- For your grandfather, this was something
that his grandchild did.
That now like another generation
is still connected to Cuba
and is still connected to that root.
I think that's really powerful.
- Hey, and if anything changes
over the next couple years,
Cuba might be a place you can go visit
and see if you can find
some more of his paintings.
You guys enjoy your food?
- I'm not done yet.
I was talking so much.
- You've been gabbing.
You got all this food,
we're in the clean plate club over here.
- Come on, Jenny, eat up.
- So now we're here with Curly.
- Hey.
- And Curly is going to call his mom.
We just pulled him out of the kitchen.
- Hi.
- [Curly] What's up?
That's my little nephew.
I have a question for you.
- Hi, mom.
- This is my co-worker.
Alright, mom.
What is something you would change
about the way you raised me?
- Uh, nothing.
- Awwww.
- Everything I did for you
is everything is excellent.
- Awww, thanks mom.
Alright, one more question.
How do you think love
changes over decades?
- Well, it changes, it changes a lot.
You know, I mean, not being
married with my husband
for 33 years now, you
know, you get married
for one day and two days, you divorce.
- My mom's a big fan of Kim Kardashian.
- What's the secret, what did you guys do?
- What's the secret?
Well, you know, I love him since,
I love him now like I met him yesterday.
- That's sweet, mom.
Alrighty, mom.
- [Henry] That was
great, thank you so much.
- Thanks mom, bye Noah.
I love you, bye mom.
- I love you too, bye-bye!
- Cool, that was wondeful.
- Thanks.
- I mean, do you feel like,
do you wish you talk to your mom,
you like ask questions
like that more often?
- Oh yeah, my mom yeah,
my mom might have--
I'm super tight with my dad,
but me and my mom are
like a little different.
- [Henry] Think about that.
Think about the questions you wish
you could ask your parents,
and then maybe just ask them.
- Yeah, I agree with that.
- Call 'em and ask.
- It's good for your grandparents too.
I do that with my grandma actually.
- Yeah, if your grandparents
are still with you,
don't take that for granted.
And with that, we'll end
this episode of Real Mature.
What a do.
- Yay!
- Say "What a do."
- What a do!
You guys say "What a do" too.
- What a do.
(light music)